[Music]
we're fishermen my granddad and me and
we could help with anything you need
but if i'm being honest we can't do a
thing until
come back soon
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for the good work evil are you
the man in charge it's my grandfather
really but he says the best besides
between you and me
i'm better at it more of a people person
you know i do
it's good to have you both of you
we've been looking for this fish for a
long time
thanks
goodbye
[Music]
i've got some new pieces with your name
on them
[Music]
i buy and sell all manner of items
what's more
we've talked so little since our first
days younley i wish i had a more
intriguing story for you
i came from sun sao
far from here for no real reason this is
not an exotic story
you measure hope yes
often
well you're most oh
i will
[Music]
only a fool would pass this up
nothing else
always a pleasure eva
happy to say i've refreshed my stocks
when you hunt any animal bring it here
for a
done for now
all done
hope to see you again soon
nice to see you
word of our growing settlement has
reached outside ears so have a look
around you may see a few new faces
i want to see the alliance map
tell me more about letter chestershire i
should like to join siegert soon he
traveled to a town called repton to meet
uber and eva ragnarsson as i hear it
they are on the verge of exiling the
current king of mercia with the hope of
installing a king of their own a bold
endeavor i should be there to help
however i can
i think you should
i won't keep them waiting good i will
send word to sigurd and the ragnasons
pledging your assistance if i were you i
would go by ship
repton is quite a distance north on the
river trent
i should go
so
our warriors now have a place to rest
and a fine shelter it is
when work gets out to the which reminds
me a few
[Applause]
[Music]
can i interest you in a game of orlock
i do miss a rattling of luck bones [__]
said the dice won't roll themselves
let us play
i'm pretty good
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
interesting
[Music]
so
the end is nice for you
how did you do that good game
ah you just got lucky
another round
i've had enough of this
ah
[Music]
some years ago i took the sea with a
sword dancer called ayden
a brooding warrior with a face of stone
and oh god arms on a radiant cola
we shored up along the edge of the
forest and explored until we came to
people parks
a large farm it was night and all were
asleep
so we set about plundering the grace
with
quiet sheep and goats as we please
[Music]
in secret we took it and the boy back to
the ship
we stand at ale bruce
when the farmers
monastery there aimour
with a crack of day they would know they
had been robbed not by whom
so ale ordered three of us to follow him
back to the sleepers
as we burned the houses ale shouted his
name i am a ill
and i am the man who deprives your
everything but your life
i never sailed with ale again
oh you have
a story from my youth
[Music]
leaders
see you
[Applause]
ziggly
need your fate
god give me strength
[Music]
ugh
[__]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
ah
me
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
so
see louie
of work there
[Music]
do your horse
thank you
[Music]
hey
sea glue
[Music]
my words
a noble deeds then
so
[Music]
with
laughter met with
[Music]
the strong
secret should be here with their agnes
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
me
lucy
so
[Music]
huh
oh
i've heard all danes are cursed with
slow brains and fat tongues
care to prove me wrong
most men choose to be loud or stupid
impressed that you manage both
i will take you on brilliant some
flighting spirit
how about
here
thank you
let us begin i have sparred against
champions and bested each one
prepare to taste bitter defeat once our
battle is done
terrible
you're a misfit a halfwit a foolish old
grouse
you're a weakling a milk sob a catcher a
laos brilliant
i'm the greatest of flighters a master
of verse
[Music]
your pride is appalling and your rhyming
is worse got you there young earth
i'm impressed
you are as sharp as that axe on your
belt as promised i will have my winnings
now take the gold
you've earned it
[Music]
foreign
so some of us are staying behind as i
hear it
half the army's already in tamworth and
we've now got help from the south
it's our lot to look after this place
now
ugh
oh
who stands before eva ragnarsson
are you sigurd strenger
igor
avor
if you keep that up
they'll stain the floors
the place could use some color
who are they
all spies
dressed to look the part of a peasant
got feisty pitchfork
from this
rabid little one
was a time when you
met and slew your enemy on the field
before they could dream of things like
sending fires
and now we shake hands and make deals
and now we shake hands and make me i
figured
i love them whipped
weeping and breaking of piss
hey
good boy
you're free saxon piggy
to run amok
mercy and fields
i would have let him down easy
huh
follow me
i'll give you the tour
what do you call this place i call it
the [__]
to the mercians it is reptile their most
revered kings are buried below the
church
imagine their weeping when we drove them
out you plunged your knife deep into the
heart of this kingdom
that is right we've got a number of
saxon nobles lined up with her lips
puckered ready to kiss our asses the
only holdout is king burgred and his war
thing leofly
but my brother is brewing a plan to deal
with that
i take it that's where we'll find my
brother right
talkers they are uber and sigurd
might want to dig the wax from your ears
don't play me for a fool upper i know
bergrid santa varga
i'm not going anywhere back right you
have the king on his heels because of me
because of my men for which you were
paid
but that price does not change because
you have caught a whiff of our hex
silver horde you forget i am a sellsword
i ask what i please and i take what i
mowed
if i wanted to hear you dark [__] i'd
gouch out your tongue and shove it up
your ass
now [__] off
hugging over silver is a bad look for
the son of ragna lovebroke but worry not
about i have the warriors you need
this is one of them
my worries are vanished ever wolf kissed
you have come at just the right time
upper and ever here are hunting a king
and when we caught him we mean to crown
another
our dear thane shellwolf here
it's not a role i begged for but it's
what mercia needs just now
a man to fairly rule both saxons and
danes
[Music]
do you have what it takes to be king
one day i hope
as it stands we at least have an
understanding
the king has refused our offers of peace
jail wolf means to change that
there'll be a new king
for a new england for now burgread is
holed up in his fortress at tamworth
making a final stand another [__]
only further south we've held a siege
there for weeks to no effect
so no more knocking now we batter the
gate to splinters
if we tape tamworth remove burgred and
crown shellwolf come mourning the shire
is ours
and mercia soon after
yes remove
i cannot stress that enough
bugred is not to be harmed my legitimacy
is king hanks on this one simple fact ah
you rob all the joy from war saxon
not every victory needs to be marked by
the slaughter of a king ah but it is
much better his request is fair
and we will honor it
jaio wolf is right to be cautious if he
shows mercy to berkelet the people will
have reason to trust him my thinking
exactly
and the quicker we act the more lives we
spare
on both sides
this is a good plan brother i am ready
for the coming fight agreed yet remember
this
whatever you stand to gain here so do we
an alliance between my clan and mercy's
crown
see this man installed on his throne and
you will have it
i swear
the bold sons of ragnar fellow to sound
the speared in and the thunder of
shields so let's fall the aerostorm the
battle begins
ah
you never said this one was a poet
i need to piss
we have a forward camp just north of
tamworth
will you go with us
lead the way
take in the sights of repton if you like
we'll be at the docks when you are ready
to go
i'm glad you and your brother have come
if only to bring some measure of calm
ease yourself chao wolf
we all stand to benefit
and you'll be remembered for this for
years to come
for all the wrong reasons i fear
a lively town quite a lot to see here
country
hmm
foreign
sail southeast
bring the men to the gates of tamworth
we'll flood the fields and pull
avor
is your rack sharpened
i'm ready for the speared in
and the thunder of shields yes
it's good to have you with us to fight
beside such legends is an honor
i've only heard tales of your conquests
now i get to live them we'll weave our
sagas together
thread upon thread come on boy
we'll forge a man from your softness
hammered on the anvil of war does not
need to fight to be move
move call me var
the fight's not here
i
the fight is nowhere to be found in this
boy a boy who happens to be gerwolf's
son
why is he not in his quarters
our future king wants a battle-hardened
heir
time he brews is worth don't you think
not yet crowned king and already
grooming his successor that shows some
boldness right
and old kings need bolder sons
he comes with us
and should anything happen to this
little sprout i will bear the punishment
our future king inflicts he'll want to
remove your head
you hear that boy
you die and i'll have to kill your
father too
mount up award it's a long ride to tom
don't worth distracted now i have to
endure my brother he always finds new
ways to humor himself
i'll keep that in mind
and both eyes open
the stink of jealousy of our budding
friendship i think
what is jayawal's son doing in repton at
all it's jail wolf's way of proving his
loyalty and there's no safer place for a
traitor and his son
in the middle of a pack of days
say from who
you and eva seem to have brought this
shire to hell beards are with us
common folk
poor
you sound different than the brothers
good ear lord most in england cannot
tell the difference
but not all danes are dangers from where
do you come if i may ask north of the
danelands a place called fonda in norway
i didn't know there was land north of
there
what are the people like you ever see a
herd of sheep follow each other off the
edge of a cliff
they're like that the ones who remained
anyway couldn't have said it better
myself
was this a mass exodus from norway then
it was
norway is now the province of a young
king harold by name a boy wise beyond
his ears are you not angry that he has
displaced you and so many others i was
for a time
but our weeks at sea have softened my
brow fire
if i'm honest
i realize i quite admire king harold my
words and by weapons both he has
pacified the country i call home for the
first time in any man's memory or any
skull song
norway has one king just one
and that is quite a feat that is
impressive truly
england is half the size of norway and
yet we have four kings for our four
kingdoms you see
how could i not be impressed
no harold is a good man with grand ideas
i can see that now i am only six years
his junior and have yet to see my first
battle
i cannot imagine the skill and cunning
he has your first battle is coming young
gilbert
from this day on
you may see rapid progress i'm not sure
i want so swift arise
in truth jailbert
it is my father who bears the heaviest
weight of my anger
not king harold my father gifted my
birthright to harold without my consent
or knowledge
as easily as if he might hand over a
battle of me it was not merely a
deception
it was a betrayal of trust
the prick of which still stings me be it
a blessing or a curse family is always
first a good line boy where are you not
an adeline i would hire you as my skull
scold
it sounds something like scott our court
poets
is that what you mean right again
fascinating
the harmony between our words and yours
is quite something as if we were distant
cousins separated by an ocean of time as
well as space
i like the thought of that i do
huh
look at these pagan rats
ravenous unseemly beasts teeming over
holy ground
have a care lord those pagan rats are
numbers i can see that fool
what do we do about them i advise we
strongly consider their demands lord we
won't survive a fight
is that you leo frit
how quickly you recover
i'm beginning to wonder if it is a man
or a god beneath all that armor
a man of god stands before you eva
proud and resolute
that's purge war thing
killed a dozen of our men in an ambush
along the river trent
it was ivar's ex that stopped him
that is a poor description of a perfect
30-yard toss
enough join heathens
speak your peace
we've come for your crown lord
with or without your head attached
i admire your ambition pagan
but what you ask is impossible
no dane ever has or ever will occupy
mercy's sacred throne
would you settle for a norse
we're not as gentle but we're much
better poets
nor stain dog
you're all the same to me oh godless
my king may i suggest a more measured
approach to this i grow weary of this
pallava
you have trampled our lands toppled our
monuments we've given you silver fed
your people
and yet in spite of all this your
encroachment on my kingdom continues
no more
we will die defending what is ours
whatsoever the cost
if you want my crown uber ragnason you
must pry it from the hands of my
bloodless corpse
man the walls
back to the camp
round up the men
we're taking tamworth tonight
hey
tell the captain we're ready to march
he learned i will round up the men
you know your way around your backswing
rap i've seen them in action
i'll be there
rattle these bones instead eh
who are you
i'm with the reconnaissance it's time to
roll out the battering ram perigrid
wanted to fight now we'll give him
let's go it's time to capture a kingdom
what are we going to do about him
something wrong
i know these men evolved i've sucked
with them
not two weeks ago leo fritz showed me
how to wield a great sword he's a friend
friendships and often at the point of a
spear
it cannot be that cold at least of all
with leopard he is only following orders
when the match begins find an empty tent
and stay there do not think me a coward
i am not afraid of war
i do not want to kill my friends
there's no other way fight or hide it's
up to
we you
[Music]
thank you
okay
destroy the gate
start of the soldiers
hmm
oh
[Applause]
no place to hide
must destroy that barricade this is our
destiny
oh
testing
are you watching
oh
hmm
protect the ramp
oh
we're fighting in
we're almost there
uh
oh
so
one by one
remember
to thrust
[Applause]
spill your brains
i'll kill you
easy
[Music]
oh much longer
we have the advantage
spill your brains
huh
no
[Music]
it's over bergrid
lay down your weapons and surrender
take three men and search the rear
look around
see what you can find
i'll send for chairwolf
tell him we found a throne
ah
that was a good scuffle
but i did notice we were short one other
link
where was the son of our king gilbert
was around and maybe you miss him your
lies are just like
[Music]
so
big
a chronicle of payments made
like a ledger
there's a symbol here
a clan emblem maybe
the brothers should see this
eva i found a letter there's a symbol
here
your men have any luck
nothing
you
this do you know that simple
toner sigil
it seems she's been dealing with burgrad
as well
the rich
she was the mercenary barking at you in
repton yes
she's playing both sides of this war she
could have told him anything
sold him secrets about me about repton
our plans
why bother with all this pageantry
fashion a new crown and stick it on your
melon there you have it you're the new
king
that is not how it works
not in mercier
you were one of bergrid's things
you must have some sense of where he'd
be
bergrid had his secret haunts
but he never told me of them
kept me quite in the dark
for good reason i suppose
toner is our only lead we talk to her
find out what she knows
i would sooner launch my face into my
axe than face her
i might improve her impression of you
we have the same father evor but his
mother was a sow
meet a zetonus camp when you're finished
here and bring your patience
and your axe
evil
a word if you would
go i'll catch up i will join the
brothers savor meet us at thomas
my son told me what happened earlier
with eva pressuring him to fight
he said you intervened you would be
mourning your son if i hadn't he's not a
fighter no but he should be
by trial all by training
he'll come around in time but keep him
from evar if you can
he's the furthest thing from a mentor
[Music]
you